foreign
[Music]
I'm Anil
and I'm Nikita
you've probably been hearing a lot of
Buzz about large language models or llms
so we're here to show you how to take
the flexibility and versatility of these
models and use them in production
applications on Google Cloud
your machine learning on Google Cloud
begins with vertex AI vertex AI provides
ml tools services workflows and
infrastructure all accessible through a
simple and unified platform now vertex
AI supports generative AI with two new
products model Garden which gives you
access to Google's latest Foundation
models like palm and a variety in
machine learning apis that span text
image code and more
the other product is generative AI
Studio which provides a simple interface
to explore prototype and customize these
generative AI models both of these
together make it easy for developers to
build with generative AI
so let's dive in and check out
generative AI Studio which lets you
quickly explore and customize generative
AI models today we'll be working with
large language models
then we'll show you how you can leverage
these models into your applications on
Google Cloud going from prototype to
production in just a few steps
one of the many reasons people are so
excited about generative AI right now is
that it allows you to prototype
applications really fast
with the right tools you can experiment
with new ideas in minutes instead of
months
you can find generative AI studio and
the vertex AI section of the cloud
console
and select the type of content for your
use case
to get started experimenting with large
language models click on new prompt
in the world of generative AI a prompt
is just a fancy name for the input text
that you feed to your model
you can get one of these models to take
on all sorts of different behaviors
based on how you structure your prompt
this Art and Science of figuring out the
best prompt for your use case is called
prompt design and it often involves a
lot of experimentation
but that's regenerative AI studio is
here to help
so let's start with the freeform prompt
one way to design a prompt is to Simply
tell the model what you want in other
words provide an instruction
for example create an outline for an
essay about hummingbirds
we click submit
and you can see that the model returns
an essay outline
so let's try something a little more
complicated
here's a synopsis of a fictional TV show
about a team of biologists working in a
lab
this Tech snippet includes both the
names of the characters as well as the
actors that played them
we can instruct the model to extract the
characters and the actors who played
them from the above message
we send this text to the model and
you can see that the model does in fact
extract the characters and the
corresponding actors that played them
with a friendly note at the end
to make this information more structured
we can even instruct the model to create
a table we just need to modify the
prompt a little bit
for an added challenge let's extract the
job that each character has in the show
as well
we'll change the prompt to say create a
table and then provide the fields we're
interested in actor character and job
and this time our model outputs a table
with the information we requested
this approach writing a single command
to get the llm to take on a certain
behavior is called zero shot prompting
now for this use case our model was able
to complete the task with just an
instruction
but depending on your use case it can be
helpful to provide some examples and
show the model what you want
that's where few shop prompting comes in
in this approach you provide the model
with a few examples
and to make it easier you can use a
structured prompt template in generative
AI Studio
the structured prompt contains a few
different components
first we have the context which
instructs how the model should respond
you can specify words the model can or
cannot use topics to focus on or avoid
or a particular response format
and the context applies each time you
send a request to the model
so if we wanted to use a structured
prompt for our use case we'll need to
add a synopsis as an example input
let's use the same one from before
we'll need to also provide the
corresponding output text in the format
that we want the llm to use
so let's say we want to establish the
text pattern actor character job so we
can easily parse the output from the llm
and store the information in a database
once we've added examples
we can test our prompt with a new
summary
the snippet here is about another
imaginary TV show and similarly contains
the names of the main characters in the
show their jobs and the actors who
played them
when we click submit you can see that
the model extracted the relevant
information and the format that we
wanted
it's important to note that adding
instructions and a few examples tends to
yield good results but at the end of the
day there's currently no best way to
write a prompt experimenting with
prompts is a core part of being a
generative AI developer you'll want to
try out different structures and formats
and examples and see what works best for
your use case and the specific model
that you're working with
so when you have a prompt that you think
is working pretty well you can save it
and return to it later
your save prompt will be visible in the
prompts Gallery which is a curated
collection of sample prompts that show
how generative AI models can work for a
variety of use cases
finally in addition to trying out
different prompts and prompt structures
there are a few model parameters you can
experiment with to try and improve the
quality of responses
first there are different models you can
choose from each model is tuned to
perform well on specific tasks
you can also specify the temperature top
p and top K these parameters all adjust
the randomness of responses by
controlling how the output tokens are
selected
when you send a prompt to the model it
produces an array of probabilities over
the words that could likely come next
and from this array we need some
strategy to decide what to return
a simple strategy might select the most
likely word at every time step but this
method can result in uninteresting and
sometimes repetitive answers
on the flip side if we were to randomly
sample over the distribution returned by
the model you might get some unlikely
responses
by controlling the degree of Randomness
you can get more unexpected and some
might even say creative responses
how you set these parameters will depend
on your use case
lastly if you want to explore additional
customizations you can tune one of the
base models for your use case
first you provide a model name
then you point to the local or cloud
storage location of your training data
your training data should be structured
as a supervised training data set and a
text to text format
each record or Row in the data will
contain the input text in other words
The Prompt followed by the expected
output of the model
after specifying the path to your data
set you can start the tuning job
and monitor the status in the cloud
console
when the tuning job completes you'll see
the tune model and the vertex AI model
registry
and you can deploy it to an endpoint for
serving or test it out in generative AI
Studio
and there you have it you've prototyped
a data extraction and organization
system in just a few minutes
now prototyping is great but to really
get the most out of your llm is to
integrate it into an app or automate a
workflow large models on vertex AI are
ready for production use let's now see
how we can scale what we did in the
generative AI Studio by using the API
Nikita was experimenting with prompts
analyzing TV summaries because let's say
in our demo scenario we run our own
content platform and we work with
creators to get their scripts into
production a different type of
production with actors and filming
we need a system where we can quickly
process and store new files with key
metadata such as a synopsis of the shows
they're working on and we want to
automatically extract the character
names and actors and store this in a
database
let's take a look at how to use the API
if you select view code you can see the
snippet you would need to use this llm
in your code
we're taking a look at python today
this code snippet is handy because it
shows us how to set up the client
library and make the request let's take
a look at the key parameters
we concatenate The Prompt and the user
input and pass through the parameters
and we're ready to go
so that when we call the API we get back
a structured response and we can use the
output to merge into a database schema
we're using bigquery a cloud relational
database in this application
our processing workflow can update the
database every time a new summary comes
in
using some common Google Cloud
components like our Google Cloud Storage
with stores our scripts and Cloud run a
serverless compute platform we can
create a processing architecture like
this
the cloud run job takes a summary runs
it through the llm by calling the vertex
API then stores the output data in
bigquery using the bigquery API with
Cloud run we can set up a trigger so
whenever a new file is stored in the
Google Cloud Storage bucket the file is
automatically passed to our Cloud run
job voila our bigquery table is
automatically populated and can easily
be rendered in a web page or app so we
can keep track of our Scripts
that was our walkthrough of our
cloud-based application that
incorporates our llm to get the maximum
use out of it there are several benefits
to using large models on Google Cloud
such as state-of-the-art models Google
maintains and upgrades for you privacy
my data is stored in my company's
private protected environment and Google
will only use it with my permission by
Enterprise ready we mean the models can
be used out of the box so you can count
on slas when you take your app to
production to serve your users
in conclusion vertex generative AI
Studio helps you design and prototype
with large language models and with the
power of cloud you can Elevate those
experiments into production as a key
component of your apps
try your own prompts in the generative
AI studio in the console and sign up for
Google Cloud innovators to stay in the
loop with the latest updates
[Music]